[Musique]
marie le bec bonjour bonjour bienvenue à
montigny le bretonneux installez-vous
bienvenue dans cet établissement qui
nous accueille pour le café politique
chaque semaine au cours du prochain
quart d'heure on va parler de vous de
votre parcours de vos engagements vous
avez à 27 ans vous êtes député de la
république en marche dans la 4e
circonscription des yvelines c'est un
secteur que vous connaissez a plutôt
bien vous avez fait une partie de vos
études à l'ancienne à saint germain en
laye ou encore à chatou le premier
engagement politique pour vous parce
qu'on va tout de suite rentré dans le
vif du sujet c'est 2007 2007 c'est l'ump
campagne pour nicolas sarkozy exactement
c'est mon premier engagement en fait mes
parents m'ont fait découvrir parce que
c'était vraiment la politique au delà du
justement parler en famille en 2004
quand j'avais 14 ans et puis après j'ai
voulu m'engager puisque devenu un peu
accro aux campagnes et voilà j'ai
continué mon engagement politique comme
ça comment ça s'est passé la découverte
du militantisme justement mais en fait
moi je dis ta vie qui parle beaucoup
politique mais pas du tout qui est pas
du tout me tente pas du tout aller sur
le terrain et puis en 2007 je trouvais
que enfin sarkozy c'était vraiment une
super ambiance une super campagne et je
me suis un peu rapproché de l'ump locale
et je commençais on m'a dit d'aller
coller des affiches on m'a dit d'aller
tracts et moi aussi j'étais je pense
dans le plus jeune a 16 ans et après fin
je trouve qu'une campagne c'est très
vivant c'est un moment où vous
rencontrer des personnes de toutes
origines de tous milieux des gens qui
n'ont pas du tout les mêmes aspirations
mais qui se regroupent tous tous pour un
candidat donc c'est un grand passionné
de la vie politique
qu'est ce qui vous a fait partir de
l'ump belle ennui profond mais là en
fait bon moi j'ai quand même été dix ans
en garde et à lui m
bon j'ai trouvé que il n'y avait pas
vraiment de volonté ni de renouvellement
du personnel qui était présent on voit
que le débat revient là avec les
différences entre ceux qui soutiennent
bédié et ceux qui ne soutiennent pas et
et puis s'en vont on était vraiment que
dans une dynamique de reconquête du
pouvoir mais pas vraiment avec des
nouvelles propositions des nouvelles
idées depuis la défaite de nicolas
sarkozy avec eux dans l'objectif un
partage un peu de qui aurait quel poste
qui serait cave responsabilité c'est pas
franchement cela quoi j'aspirais et donc
j'ai faim j'ai rejoint un petit peu en
marche ce que je crois qu'il maniait
mâcon à une personnalité intéressante et
voir parce que ça donne et puis
finalement j'ai totalement adhéré aux
portables dont parlait de l'ump vous
parliez de la république en marche et le
parti socialiste aux siens pendant dix
huit mois vous avez été attaché
parlementaire aussi d'une effectué
socialiste christian franqueville en
fait en sortant de mes études donc j'ai
fait un master affaires publiques et
représentation des entreprises
donc c'est à dire accompagner les
entreprises dans leurs relations avec
les pouvoirs les institutions et les
pouvoirs politiques et il y avait cette
opportunité en fait d'être
collaboratrice et vous monsieur c'est
une bonne opportunité jusqu'au moins je
connaîtrais de l'intérieur le
fonctionnement de l'assemblée nationale
va que de manière théorique il m'a
jamais demandé quels étaient mes
convictions politiques je le lui ai pas
donné
bon c'est vrai que le principal frein
quand on a fait l'entretien en mauges
qui m'a dit moi mon sujet numéro un
serment l'emploi et le maintien
d'emplois dans l'est dans les vosges
j'estime l'emploi c'est ni gauche ni
droite je pense qu'on peut le trouver
un terrain d'entente et bon c était
vraiment une expérience très
enrichissante que j'étais à la fois à
l'assemblée puis après je suis parti
dans la deuxième partie un petit peu de
l'emploi là bas dans les vosges donc
cette volonté de devenir député est pas
venu tout de suite faire quand vous avez
rallié le mouvement en marche pour la
campagne présidentielle vous ne vous
êtes pas dit si ça va bien j'ai
peut-être moyen de faire une petite
carrière politique de m'engager
télévisée enfin j'ai toujours été très
intéressé par la politique et forcément
quand vous êtes investi dans un parti où
toujours mais peut-être que je pourrai
un jour être dans une mairie dans une
équipe municipale ou ou même plus
forcément vous y penser parce que quand
vous êtes engagé vous avez aussi envie
de toujours vous engagez plus mais non
pour marche
d'ailleurs je croyais pas du tout qui
amèneront pouvait gagner enfin elle vous
rappelle un mes premiers souvenirs c'est
quand je discute avec le référent
départemental de en marche qui dit oui
dans 12 mois il est présent et gitane
mais ce gars est fou moi je la fais
dix ans que la politique jamais
quelqu'un qui est qui émerge comme ça
arrive à remporter une élection
et puis en fait j'ai un peu passé toute
la campagne des présidentielles à dire
quand même c'est fou ce qu'on arrive à
faire avec en marche et du coup voilà
j'ai enfin je pensais pas admis est
investi fin je pense pas candidate et
puis j'ai eu le soutien de quelques
militants donc je vais déposer une
candidature que je pensais pas être
investis budget investi pour ce va être
élu et j'ai été élu donc ça a été une
surprise en surprise et dans votre
famille vous l'avez dit on parlait
politique on parle politique ils ont
réagi comment cet engagement alors à en
marche et puis aussi le fait de passer
le cap et d'être candidate et puis
ensuite élu député
déjà ça n'a pas été facile c'était un
gros travail de conviction parce que
manager de cette famille qui a toujours
été historiquement engagé à droite de la
droite libérale très tournée vers
l'économie d'entreprise et du coup c'est
vrai qu'il avait un peu l'impression que
c'était le sous marin de françois
hollande et beaucoup de débats trahison
ça là c'est un peu pourquoi tu liras
gauche
et puis enfin progressivement je les ai
convaincus dont je pense que un peu un
élément de conviction que ça a été
forcément quand j'étais investi des très
contents très fiers donc ça aide
toujours et
et puis maintenant je pense qu'ils sont
assez satisfait du quinquennat pour
l'instant elle en parlait du parcours
politique ya aussi un parcours
professionnel puisque vous avez fait un
début de carrière en tant que lobbyiste
tout à fait et on vous l'a reproché
aussi
ouais on avoue non mais en fait on en a
beaucoup parlé pendant la campagne et
après quand on est arrivé à l'assemblée
il y avait quelques articles très
agressif sur le sujet l'entrée des
lobbystes à l'assemblée nationale moi ce
que j'ai appris en étant lobbystes c'est
qu'en fait vous avez le monde économique
le monde politique ces deux mondes qui
interagissent énormément l'un sur
l'autre et qu'ils se parlent pas moi
quand je vois quand j'étais lobbystes je
constate que les entreprises souvent
élise a oui je vais avoir tel sujet mais
elle pense pas une seule seconde à
alerter les politiques sur ces sujets là
et maintenant que je suis député je me
je constate que en fait souvent vous
voulez essayer de rencontrer des acteurs
qui vont pouvoir vous parler de deux
thématiques sur lesquelles vous
travaillez et vous savez pas tellement
qui vous adressez parce qu'il ya une
trop grande diversité et je pense que le
lobby style fait le lien entre ces deux
là parce qu'il connaît bien les deux
mondes
il les fréquente et je pense que c'est
absolument fondamental mais
effectivement ça a été un gros sujet je
pense que la vision du look bling en
france à l'air elle n'est pas hyper
positive mais vu le travail a essayé de
revaloriser ce métier qui est je pense
important parcours politique métier âge
on vous a fait beaucoup de reproches
pendant la campagne nous on fait encore
peut-être aujourd'hui c'est difficile le
monde politique mais vous l'avez vécu
vous le vivez comment moi je trouve que
c'est moins que plus on vous a beaucoup
sollicités dans les médias oui parce que
votre âge je sais oui ça c'est vrai
non en fait je trouve que quand même
c'est moins dur qu'avant notamment dans
la place des femmes j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait vraiment une évolution je pense
que aussi un peu un phénomène
générationnel
je trouve qu'il ya moins ce rapport
justement hommes femmes enfin en tout
cas moi aussi avec les députés de mon
âge je trouve que les relations sont
beaucoup plus apaisées après oui c'est
un c'est passionnant mais c'est dur
parce que effectivement vous êtes quand
même dans la représentation et ça veut
dire que en fait on attend toujours que
vous soyez à 100% et et pour ça c'est
difficile et je comprends qu'en même
temps quand
vous avez mis deux mois à obtenir un
rendez vous avec votre député parce que
son agenda est plein quand vous voyez
vous attendez à ce qu'ils soient au top
à 100% est totalement dispose donc c'est
sûr que c'est pas c'est pas facile les
médias c'est aussi une bonne expérience
mais c'est aussi assez challenging si on
peut dire qu'il est donc elle n'en sait
pas c'est évident mais vous êtes coacher
pour ça tout à fait j'avais un coach on
peut juste en parler parce que là aussi
ça a été médiatisée c'est laurent
fontaine l'ancien animateur télé qui et
qui aujourd'hui fait du coaching et
c'est lui qui vaut coach ça se passe
bien les séances de coaching le wado
quinze jours donc on verra c'est ce
qu'ils ont dit mais non franchement ça
se passe bien moi j'avais faim je pense
qu'on en avait vraiment besoin
honnêtement c'est un exercice auquel on
n'est pas du tout habituée alors au
début il ya eu un côté un peu fraîcheur
nouveautés et qui est sympa mais surtout
avant je faisais beaucoup de plateau où
j'étais seul avec les interviewer et
honnêtement ils jouent pas toujours le
jeu quand tu vois vous êtes en
difficulté ils font un peu de sujet
enfin sauf certains mais globalement et
en fait quand vous commencez à être avec
des opposants politiques vous avez très
peu de temps de parole on s'écoute pas
toujours donc c'est il faut être
percutant tout de suite et transmettre
la bonne information et ça c'est un
exercice qui est même avec un peu
d'entraînement et l'expérience c'est pas
un exercice facile à part seul en
plateau on change de sujet les
journalistes quand vous êtes un peu en
difficulté peut-être que vous allez être
en difficulté sur ce sujet c'est la
réforme ferroviaire
ah non ça je vous travaillé dessus c'est
forcément d'actualité sur le mois
d'avril avec ces grèves qui sont
annoncés jusqu'au mois de juin
ces manifestations qui se poursuivent
ses usagers qui sont pénalisés est qui
et qui ont parfois du mal aussi
c'est quoi le message à faire presser
pour que les choses avancent ça veut
dire que c'est impossible de réformer
que le gouvernement va devoir revenir
aussi sur ce qui a été prévu
alors non il faut absolument que le
gouvernement revienne sur ses objectifs
c'est une réforme qui est ambitieuse
selon ce qu'on fait on parle beaucoup de
par exemple la dette le statut des
cheminots etc
il faut juste rappeler que le fond du
sujet c'est l'ouverture à la concurrence
c'est à dire comment est ce qu'on va
faire pour faire que la sncf
quand on va faire entrer de nouveaux
acteurs des 11 nouvelles entreprises
ferroviaires puisse s'adapter puisse
perdurer
et ne se retrouve pas dans des
situations difficiles comme certaines
entreprises françaises qui étaient avant
publics sont devenus quand quand leur
statut a changé quand de nouveaux
opérateurs sont arrivés donc l'ouverture
à la concurrence en gros pour moi il ya
deux grands sujets il ya d'une re
définir en fait on va passer à une
politique nationale à des politiques de
transport régional et des politiques des
lignes d'intérêt national donc tgv ça
c'est le premier sujet donc il faut re
définir comment les pouvoirs vont
s'articuler entre les différentes
autorités organisatrices de transport et
puis ensuite le deuxième sujet c'est de
dire ok donc ça veut dire qu'on va
devoir transmettre un certain
d'information aux autorités
organisatrices pour qu'elles puissent
faire des appels d'offre définir comment
est ce qu'elles veulent s'organiser
est-ce que c'est plutôt de la régie est
ce que c'est plutôt la délégation de
service public donc voilà c'est cesser
creed ces conditions là vraiment qu'ils
sont le fond la discussion après
effectivement ça implique aussi le
statut des cheminots parce que pour être
compétitive il faut faire évoluer ce
statut donc il ya des négociations qui
sont en cours
et puis il ya la question de la dette et
de
l'organisation de la sncf pour l'instant
on est un epic il faut que ce statut
change en société nationale à capitaux
publics voilà il ya c'est une réforme
qui est ambitieuse je comprends qu'elles
suscitent des angoisses c'est vrai qu'on
a vu parfois des secteurs qui ont été
ouverts à la concurrence qui est des
grandes entreprises françaises ont été
extrêmement pénalisé et en même temps
c'est une source d'opportunités parce
que quand vous fait rentrer de la
confiance vous êtes plus innovants vous
cherchez à être plus créatifs
pour le consommateur ça fait aussi
baisser les prix des billets et je pense
qu'il ya personne qui vous dira pas que
le billet paris bordeaux pour aller sur
le bassin d'arcachon et pas trop et
abordable et c'est donc voilà il ya il
ya vraiment des avantages donc le texte
il n'est pas figé il bouge mais il faut
que tout le monde soit prêt à discuter
avec un planning comme celui ci vous
n'avez plus beaucoup de temps pour vous
vous le regrettez est-ce que vous
pratiquez toujours le badminton non non
c'est terrible mais devant les passages
du film plus de fort non non c
c'est ouais c'est il ya plus beaucoup de
temps personnel j'aimerais que le c'est
ça le plus dur presque c'est pas pour
moi parce que je vis des choses
passionnantes mais pour mes proches pour
ma famille en fait on a très peu de
temps alors alors consacré est parfait
c'est difficile donc effectivement non
j'ai pu ni le temps de cuisiner ni de
faire d badminton par mois est ce que je
vais faire avant mais pas grave une
dernière question l'été dernier vous
disiez que vous pensiez un peu à la
présidence de la république c'est
toujours le cas non mais je trouve que
cette fois on a été terriblement
d'efforts mais on m'a demandé ce que je
fais ou est ce que je me voyais à 1
trente six ans dans dix ans et si j mais
il faut se donner des objectifs
inatteignables pour avancer mais j'en
sais rien je veux dire y aller il faut
être réaliste il ya très peu début il ya
très peu de ce que ce que je veux c'est
que en gros l'action que je mène
aujourd'hui en tant que député soit
reconnu et que cet ex ça cette
reconnaissance qui me permette d'avancer
et d'évoluer après honnêtement
sincèrement la politique je sais pas un
métier c'est pour ça que j'avais été
lobbyiste c'était pour allier
enfin ma passion pour la politique et en
même temps une carrière en tant que
salarié mais on verra enfin ajouter le
monde a tellement changé là depuis
quelques mois que bercy la bête d'avoir
participé à cette émission du café
politique député de la 4e
circonscription des yvelines
[Musique]
oh